c'était en août 2010 8 les usagers ont
découvert stupéfaits de longue fissure
dans la chaussée de l'échangeur
par sécurité des voies ont dû être
fermées les camions interdits et les
embouteillages sur cet axe menant d'un
côté au port et de l'autre ou chu ont
empoisonné le quotidien dé martinique
deux ans plus tard nous sommes en fin de
travaux et la chaussée sans le goudron
chaud
si l'usager ne remarque que presque rien
c'est que le chantier se déroule
principalement la nuit
en effet jusqu'à 100000 véhicules jour
circulent en moyenne sur cet échangeur
l'ensemble des travaux d'enrobés
d'éclairage public
le dispositif de sécurité et de marquage
ce fond de nuit
l'ouverture totale fin des travaux d'ici
quelques jours
alors là les travaux sont pratiquement
achevés on est en travaux de finition
donc ce qu'il nous reste à faire c'est à
finaliser le marquage a déposés soit et
les glissières en béton préfabriqué qui
sont là donc l'ensemble des travaux
seront terminés au plus tard en fin de
semaine prochaine pas ainsi bientôt les
véhicules en provenance de chateauboeuf
retrouveront leurs bretelles qui permet
de bifurquer directement vers
l'autoroute direction sud
l'affaissement de la zone et des dieux à
d'importantes fuites d'eau en souterrain
qu'il a fallu détecter et réparer afin
de consolider les changer on a
effectivement trouvé de l'eau chlorée au
niveau de glissements lors ya eu une
collaboration de l'ensemble des
partenaires
ce soit bon bien sûr au dc qui le
fermier aussi bien val meunière et aussi
bien aussi l'ensemble des collectivités
ainsi que la ville de fort de france
puisqu'on est sur le territoire de la
ville quoi en réalité la partie la plus
importante du chantier se trouve en
contrebas l'échangeur à rivière roche
ici une paroi clouée de près de 100
mètres de long permet de soutenir le
talus et la nationale un ouvrage assez
exceptionnel en martinique
puisque les 340 cloud qui le
maintiennent s'enfonce entre 8 et 30
mètres et sedrun continueront d'évacuer
toute circulation d'eau ce sont des
draps qui fait entre 20 45 mètres de
profondeur dans qui rentre dans la terre
de 20 45 mètres et qui dépasse la voirie
qui est au dessus donc on dépasse
lorsque les deux voies lorsqu'on voit en
direction du sud
c'est des choses qui arrivent et on ne
fait pas des drains de 45 mètres donc
de profondeur tous les jours les deux
phases du chantier auront coûté à la ctm
3 millions d'euros une procédure est
d'ailleurs en cours pour déterminer
toutes les responsabilités